hey guys L to go gets Justine welcome
back to my kitchen today you don't have
to watch me bake a cake because how many
times I've baked cakes on my channel a
lot you know the process
today we're making a pac-man themed cake
III is coming up so I wanted to do
something really fun and video game
inspired and I thought a pac-man cake
that sounds really really easy
so to start got these little tiny
cupcakes that I'm also going to ice to
go around so it's kind of like a little
balls the pac-man eats during the game
also gonna make some cherry and I've got
some icing that I'm going to die yellow
so I guess to get started I'm just going
to cut out his little mouth I think that
looks perfect actually now I needed to
go the other way
oops you can eat over here now I'm going
to die alright in yellow I press
everything with the icing I forgot a lot
of die except a little pac-man oh maybe
it should have been a little more yellow
mmm
it's vintage he's been aging he's aged
very well leave him alone oops he's been
left out what's gone a little too long
sorry
[Music]
they aren't happy with what we've got
going on so far when the clean up around
the edges put his eye on and we just
keep going where's the pork Jack you
thankful again cuz I kind of want to
bounce it a little bit
oh there we go oh that's quite hop
that's melting now ok well that's
exactly what I wanted to do so here's a
nice greasy I back man is looking good
now we're going to ice up some of these
little guys for his little balls now I
don't think my cherry
[Music]
oh yeah one last one and we're good to
go
I make a journal so good yeah thank you
the yellow had a minute big time Angela
could be white other things
that's why I've got cherries oh the
balls might be white in the game now but
I think about it dark they're different
color balls there's like a little ghost
city
a lot of things it looks really bad in
front of you hey now hey now - and taste
it no we've eaten so many cake all day
normally I said yeah but it was good I'm
gonna say but I'm actually - put in the
freezer and save it well thank you guys
so much for watching and thank you
Jennifer approving of my beautiful
artwork very nice
happy III I'll see you guys there
[Music]
you
[Music]